[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días nos
encontramos en la ciudad de quibdó en la
región del pacífico colombiano y estamos
aquí para la cuarta edición del kit de
áfrica y el festival
[Música]
el aplicación festival fue creado hace
cuatro años en la ciudad de quibdó por
iniciativa de wilfried massamba un
cineasta congoleño que lleva años
viviendo en colombia este festival que
contribuye a tejer lazos entre el
continente africano y su diáspora es
cada vez más conocido entre los amantes
del cine es también una oportunidad para
que la población de egipto descubra
producciones cinematográficas
independientes veamos el siguiente
reportaje para esta edición 2022 del
festival fueron seleccionadas a más de
100 películas con el tema de la herencia
como hilo conductor al estar por ejemplo
aquí en colombia hay mucho contenido que
no conocemos del continente africano de
los diferentes países entonces este
festival ha posibilitado ver
muchas películas realizadas en el
continente africano y también entender
las diferentes formas de entender el
mundo y la cosmovisión y estas películas
están posibilitando ese diálogo
intercontinental el quid de áfrica film
festival es una plataforma de
exploración que presenta largometrajes
cortometrajes y documentales así como
conversatorios y exposiciones
hemos sido tan adoctrinados que el único
cine que conocemos el cine occidental
eso nos permitió comprender que áfrica
tiene mucho que aportar no solamente el
folclore sino también cine no había como
digamos que un lugar especial para
hablar de cine la producción de cine
afro en el país entonces me parece que
también es un lugar de reivindicación de
descentralizar también la producción
audiovisual y sobre todo pues de la
diáspora africana en colombia desde la
primera edición del festival que todo se
está convirtiendo cada vez más en un
punto de encuentro para los amantes del
séptimo arte una oportunidad para esta
ciudad donde la cultura siempre ha
tenido un lugar central y equidad áfrica
and feel festival es una oportunidad
para que esa juventud tenga en el cine
una opción de desarrollo el ministerio
de cultura de colombia así como
importantes instituciones reconocen este
encuentro que aspira ahora a crecer ya
consolidarse para permitir más
intercambios entre el continente
africano y américa latina
cuando whitman samba el director del
festival visitó por primera vez hace
unos 20 años quedó fascinado por esa
ciudad de la que nunca había oído hablar
y que en muchos aspectos le recordaba a
cuatro a su ciudad natal en el congo
apasionado por el cine y convencido de
que ese arte es la forma más eficiente
de compartir y dialogar decidió crear un
festival aquí nos lo cuenta en la
siguiente entrevista
nos puedes explicar cómo quedó una
ciudad del pacífico colombiano se ha
convertido en un lugar de encuentro para
la promoción del cine africano
es curioso porque cuando descubrí que
cuando descubrí no como cristóbal colón
pero cuando vine aquí por primera vez
hace apenas cinco años me di cuenta de
que había lo sabía más o menos pero al
estar aquí me encontré con la población
afrocolombiana con la gente negra
afrodescendiente que hay en esta región
fue para mí un choque emocional un shock
cultural porque no me hubiera imaginado
esto
otro conocía un poco la costa atlántica
donde existe una mezcla y mestizaje de
poblaciones pero aquí me encuentro con
esta gente que puedes encontrar en el
continente africano en el congo senegal
en camerún en cualquier lugar de áfrica
fue un gran shock para mí muchas cosas
en mi pensé que era aquí donde tenía que
estar que era aquí donde tenía que estar
porque viniendo de áfrica llegar aquí me
permitió también buscar mi propia
identidad
desde allí tenemos gente que fue llevada
y probablemente yo también tengo un
familiar que fue llevado así que es una
forma de buscar mi propia identidad
como reacción a los profesionales
africanos cuando les hablas de un
festival de cine africano en quibdó qué
significa para ellos y cómo responden a
tu invitación y músico dónde está aquí
la primera respuesta a mi invitación es
donde yo no busco lo busco la mayoría me
pregunta eso y les hago entender que
aquí hay una gran población
afrocolombiana la gente se centra sobre
todo en brasil pero colombia tiene la
segunda mayor población afrodescendiente
del mundo así que les digo que aquí hay
una población que es similar a nosotros
y que desea conocer las culturas
africanas hay una fuerte demanda aquí e
intento explicar a los cineastas
africanos que es muy importante que
poder mostrar lo que hacen y que vengan
aquí también quiero miren sólo hacia
europa si nos transversalmente hacia
américa latina porque aquí hay una
comunidad aquí 400 millones de
afrodescendientes en américa latina así
que hay un público para las culturas
africanas y trato de hacer entender a
los directores africanos
y que sus productos audiovisuales deben
ser presentados aquí creo que lo
entienden entre los invitados del
festival un director senegalés maxilar y
no a presentar una película titulada del
maestro lavar sostén este documental es
el resultado de cinco años de
investigación sobre la vida y la obra
artística del abad o sea uno de los
primeros músicos en popularizar los
ritmos cubanos en áfrica
la película invita al espectador a
seguir al artista desde gambia hasta
senegal pasando por cuba y eeuu
escuchemos mi película se llama el
maestro lava su se habla de un cantante
de música afrocubana llamado el abad o
sea que nació en gambia creció en
seminal tuvo estamos loco por la música
afrocubana desde que era un adolescente
que milagrosamente se convirtió en una
de las grandes estrellas de esta música
en todo caso uno de los mayores
embajadores de la música afrocubana en
áfrica
yo nunca había oído hablar de quibdó y
gracias a un festival de cine me
encuentro aquí defendiendo una película
china africa por africanos
con y que cuenta la historia de un
africano que gracias a la música
afrocubana se conectó también con el
continente americano y el caribe además
de presentar esta película este festival
fue la ocasión de un encuentro
excepcional entre el director maquila y
quibdó una ciudad donde los
afrocolombianos representan más del 80%
de la población este lugar es una
oportunidad para recordar la presencia
de áfrica en américa latina acompañamos
a maki sealine su recorrido de esta
ciudad para el desconocida pero familiar
cuando maquis y la aceptó la
convocatoria al kit de áfrica festival
no hubiera sospechado que esta ciudad
del pacífico colombiano a miles de
kilómetros de su casa le recordaría
tanto a su tierra natal la casa mansa en
el sur de senegal
se parece a casa mancha es hermoso
es exactamente como la
naturaleza de los marcos las piraguas la
gente el olor en realidad es un
poco de emociones hay muchas emociones
porque no sabía que había tantos afros
aquí en colonias de costera john william
de fondant fabricante y ahora descubra
esta región donde hay más del 80% de
afrodescendientes que en los mayores de
la procuración que es tu selección de
contra fica no toma bien general y
descubro que una gran mayoría de la
población viene de las costas africanas
particularmente de senegal gambia y tan
mal
me pongo a pensar que en realidad no
vine aquí por el festival sino para
conocer afrodescendientes familiares
míos la historia nos ha separado pero
estamos reunidos por este golpe del
destino de lo que ya están una reunión
que fue también celebrada por 15 años
muchas gracias hermanos gracias hola
hasta luego
paradójicamente aunque áfrica sigue
estando muy presente en esta parte de
américa latina hay pocos intercambios
entre los dos continentes
hay un poco contacto entre los afros de
américa latina y los de áfrica conocemos
a los jamaiquinos a los afroamericanos
del norte y también a los brasileños en
cierta medida pero en colombia venezuela
panamá ecuador
muy poco contacto con estas poblaciones
y creo que es el momento a través de
iniciativas como el festival de cripto
de reparar este error bloque de festival
de qatar ha estado en esta ciudad se
encuentra un lugar que guarda conexión
con la historia el mundo one two es un
museo que recorre la tragedia de la
esclavitud con el objetivo de devolver
la memoria de este pasado a quienes
llevan su huella juntos
centro de memoria documentación y marte
realidad es donde se narra qué pasó
cuando pasó donde pastor
los victimarios de aquellas personas
africanas que fueron secuestradas
extraídas a nuevo
esta apuesta es única y en la diferencia
más grande en latinoamérica mont ventoux
haciendo preferencia a que la
investigación no fueron demostrando que
la gran mayoría de población a sor juana
es originaria de la región bantú cuando
hablamos de la región magnitud estamos
hablando de áfrica central de los países
del congo de guinea ecuatorial de gabón
de angola entre otros
áfrica profundamente conmovido por el
relato del calvario de la esclavitud
contada por descendientes de los que lo
vivieron en carne propia maquila no
contiene su emoción
es la primera vez que me encuentro con
personas que descienden de esta tragedia
terrible que es un crimen contra la
humanidad estoy emocionado porque
fue esa misma emoción que sintió sergio
mosquera cuando visitó hace unos años el
mina una ciudad de ghana que se
convirtió en el siglo 17 en uno de los
principales centros de la trata de
personas el menor
entré en el show sea estar en un
castillo eso es uno que vaya cae a
despuntar media cuenta que fue real
la visita de maquis y la cuido le causó
una fuerte impresión y le dio nuevas
ideas el director busca ahora una forma
de perpetuar el vínculo ancestral que ha
podido recuperar gracias a un festival
de cine la película ganadora del premio
del jurado del festival es band tu mamá
la historia de una mujer
franco-camerunés a que consigue escapar
tras ser detenida en la república
dominicana encuentra refugio en el
barrio más peligroso de santo domingo
donde es acogida por un grupo de niños
lo que cambiará su destino para siempre
hablamos con el director de la película
iván herrera y la actriz principal
clarice al brest tiene una película que
tiene obviamente una conexión importante
con la madre tierra pero también con
europa el triángulo
en el que hemos históricamente
no porque somos parte de atrás de la
trata trasatlántica
europa áfrica y el caribe y obviamente
hace esa conexión y es importante que
nosotros
exponemos esto en la película y que
todos puedan ver un poco de estas
culturas
decidimos retratar ese ese ambiente
urbano de una forma diferente pero al
mismo tiempo de aportar nuestra visión
sobre la conexión entre áfrica europa y
el caribe aquí termina la edición de
esta semana y gracias por estar con
nosotros la información sigue en france
24 y trans 24 punto com